hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ihr habt ja bereits im titel
gesehen meine reaktion auf pcs das sind
diese netten jungs die machen musik
falls du dich kennen solltet ich
reagiere allerdings heute nicht auf die
musik von denen denn das label von bt es
geht ziemlich hart gegen reactions mit
urheberrechts ansprüchen vor sondern wir
reagieren heute auf das video bts gibt's
dann ficki ficki demmin schlägt wie
episode 28 viel liebe von der lieben
youtube in korea janin ich konnte mich
ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr retten vor den
ganzen kommentaren dass sich darauf mal
reagieren soll die macht in ihren videos
hier solche zusammenschnitte von den
bann tannhäuser aus interviews
irgendwelche aufnahmen wo sie gesehen
wurden und sie spricht darüber
auf deutsch allerdings ist es nicht die
richtige besetzung sondern das was sie
sich vorstellt was eventuell nur
übersetzung sein könnte allerdings würde
ich sagen staat mal mit dem video gesagt
ich will nichts von dir ein himmelszelt
ich nicht glaube dass nicht alles fallen
[Musik]
ich bin halt überhaupt nicht drin in der
ganzen kay popszene allerdings verstehe
ich halt gerade überhaupt keine
hintergründe also ich weiß nicht wer mit
wem geschickt wird und ich kann auch
nicht die namen von den ganzen leuten da
die musik von bts ist megageil da steht
außer frage ich bin auch in meiner
spotify playlist ganz oben links bei der
players findet ihr unten in der video
beschreibung eingeblendet da könnte auch
gern mal drauf klicken und könnten
folgen auf polizei dass man für die
ganzen lieder die ich gerade tut aber
wahrscheinlich eh niemanden das stimmt
es ist china wo es geht und vorsichtig
an staub der klärung des fc hude fahren
okay
[Musik]
also ich verstehe daher ist nicht dumm
der bast hat das war so völlig aus -
einfach mal rente beleidigt ich glaube
das spiel bleibt nicht nur kannst es
besteht also völlig aus dem nichts
machen ich muss doch operiert die kann
man auch nicht zu trauen
dafür werde ich das spiel spiele als
gerade ja alles klar das spiel ist aber
eigentlich echt ganz nice also ich
glaube das könnte auch gut spielen soll
ich das auch meinem video spielen
nein kann ich mich zu dir setzen ich war
von den anderen mal ganz kurz ich hab
natürlich keinen plan was da gerade
abgeht und ich glaube sehr viele von
euch also von meinen zuschauern wissen
auch nicht was da abgeht natürlich klar
viele verfolgen auch die bank haben boys
und wissen was da alles ist allerdings
sieht es für mich ein bisschen so aus
als wären die sonne big brother nach
mache und er wird hier gerade jetzt
wieder schlafen geht gefilmt dass ich
meine privatsphäre haben privatsphäre
du wirst kann von einer kamera gefilmt
während du schlafen gehen willst ja also
ich konnte ja auch immer ob jemand in
mein bett gepisst aber jetzt erst mal
schön ins bett legen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die typischen fragen die man sich
stellen wenn man schlafen gehen will
ich kann mit recht die briefe schreiben
auch wieder so eine typische standard
problem höhere deine gedanken ja ich hab
kein problem damit
ich bin es leid wie cora das lachen so
richtig realitätsnah nachstellt dirigent
man selbst zugeben liebe es ich hätte
damit niemals aufhören wann bist du kann
wenn junge penan geht jetzt aber alle fr
gefragt so hellmann gesten penan der
andere antwortet ganz normal und seine
funktionen darauf dass jemand drauf
gefallen ist so glaube ich aber dann
kann noch spielen schon 22 uhr es ist 22
uhr die larven hat die ganze zeit so von
wegen ey alter penan gene schon voll mit
der nach 22 uhr
ich bin nicht müde was das eigentlich
ein mini billardtisch
die spielen der die ganze zeit auf so
miniatur billardtisch billard haben wir
halt doch zusammen bist du sehr gern
gibt es dann ficki ficki sag ich nicht
dann würde ich jetzt müde
das ist einfach so ohne sind irgendwas
aneinandergereiht gibt's dann ficki
ficki
lach ich drüber so war es ist zeit ins
bett zu gehen
übrigens zum kicken sehen
was
[Musik]
ich bin echt sauer
es passiert ja gerade schlagen die ihm
jetzt alle nacheinander auf den arsch
ich bin so nett und kochen noch für alle
kochen
das ist ein wasserkocher was gibt's denn
bei denen zu essen heißen tee und dann
mit eiswürfeln als nachtisch oder hecke
kopf gestellt so ein gericht von lecker
gedeckter es heißt das oft das ist das
ist so richtig japanisches fernsehen
einfach sonne flammen animation wenn die
grillen braucht ein gesicht das wenden
sich wohl dank übersehen dass ich mich
halt dass ich hatte es zuerst gehabt was
weiß ich mich ein bisschen frage ist das
zum teil zumindest die echte übersetzung
ich kann auch wie es von uns lange
benutzen dann haben wir auch zum lachen
ich kann auch seine hand lange benutzen
geld für die auch das schon fast fertig
ist irgendwie alles stimmt alter fotos
noch jeder irgendwie penan gegangen und
jetzt gewählt die auf einmal alle
draußen
ist das ein
[Musik]
steger hat gar nichts mehr wurden die
bank kann bis jetzt wirklich alle
zusammen in dieser villa und haben da
einfach da die küche die so echt nicht
so geil aussieht aber dann so bruhn
direkt daneben also wenn ihr dann plan
von habt könnt ihr mir gern mal unten in
die kommentare schreiben
diese mir jemand sagen ich kann helfen
also die zwei werden geschickt oder ist
ja schon lange warten auf dich okay das
sollte auch fertig sein
also das sieht echt hardcore klaus und
vorhersage halt noch die kräfte aus
[Musik]
plötzlich wieder aufmarsch des gallardo
ich mache immer erkennt nicht der einen
kumpel im freundeskreis der immer die
teller daher von allen anderen ablegt
ja lecker mich gesagt einfach aus wir
sind nicht fertig vorsichtig waren wie
das ist noch so ein spaß
ich habe gar keinen plan was er bei
denen ab geht es kann endlich essen
kommen darf ich den tanz
den noch mal sehen ich finde ja schon
die performance ist und die choreografin
geil wenn die irgendwie in ihren
musikvideos rumtanzen und zweitens wort
aber dass das ad hoc wirklich alles es
gibt geschmack ratten klassisches
japanisches grillgerät erst mal wichtig
klassen die wichtig wie es genug oder
das war s das war das video ich habe
nicht verstanden um was es geht zum ist
anders so viele von euch haben halte
meine kommentare geschrieben unter die
letzten videos überall auf instagram
keine ahnung wo luca du musst unbedingt
auf corian reagieren das habe ich jetzt
jemand getan ich finde es mega geil wie
viel arbeit du cora in diese videos
reinsteckt allerdings bin ich halt 0
drin in der szene und ich weiß jetzt
nicht was irgendwie abgehen und ich habe
es auch part 28 geguckt also eigentlich
vielleicht hätte ich mit part 1 anfangen
sollen da aber die ganzen reaction hier
für mich ziemlich verwirrend allerdings
trotzdem an einigen stellen echt mega
unterhaltsam unserem dummer stumpfer
humor also das feierlich mega wenn euch
das video heute gefallen hat dann das
gerne einen daumen hoch da das würde
mich sehr freuen und schreibt mir
unbedingt unten in die kommentare falls
ihr ahnung von bts hat otto ramin kennt
was ist das ich hab keine ahnung was ich
mir gerade angeschaut habe ich eventuell
die nächste mal ein video hochladen wie
ich auf die richtige musik von bts
reagiere dann schreibt man auch unten in
die kommentare ich weiß nicht ob ich das
wirklich hochladen kann und ob es dann
auch online bleibt weil wie gesagt das
label von denen die sind ein bisschen
reactions und das mögen wir nicht so
gern dabei wenn ich da bock drauf hat
dann werde ich mir auf jeden fall
irgendwie was einfallen lassen abonniert
main kanal falls sie noch kein teil der
luke schulzeit und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]